a team of Russian scientists is working
hard to resurrect this quintessential
Ice Age behemoth in a high-five
but what if they never disappeared in
the first place and still roamed the
Arctic regions on earth what would they
eat and would we hunt them for their
tusks
they have adapted this is what if and
here's what would happen if mammoths
never went extinct the shaggy-haired
herbivores are cousins to the modern-day
Asian elephant weighing in at almost 6
metric tons and around 3 to 4 meters
tall they were similar in size to the
African elephant still large but not as
mammoth as we like to imagine woolly
mammoths only went extinct about 10,000
years ago their fossils are found across
North America Asia Europe and Africa
so what happened to them woolly mammoths
who were built for sub-zero arctic
habitats a main reason they were able to
thrive during the Ice Age was because of
a particularly quirky circulatory flow
their counter current system feeds
venous blood through the heart and lungs
and arterial blood through the legs and
feet this is opposite to how human blood
circulates their blood itself was also
special and kept oxygen flowing at
frigid temperatures sort of like
antifreeze in your car this unique blood
system allowed them to stay warm in ice
cold weather and operate off of limited
calories while still conserving heat and
maintaining blood flow it didn't hurt
that their exterior hair could grow up
to 1 metre long wooly indeed
so is climate change to blame for their
extinction scientists haven't come to a
conclusion yet it's still debated
whether climate change which altered
their ecosystems or humans who hunted
them were the driving factor of their
annihilation probably a little bit of
both but what if they somehow survived
our Arctic regions would look a lot
different and not just because there
would be jumbo sized shaggy animals
roaming around there would be less elk
moose and caribou because the woolly
mammoth would out-compete them for food
woolly mammoths ate around 225 kilograms
of plants daily they would sweep aside
snow with their giant tusks to access
grass compacted under permafrost this
grazing style creates a cycle that
favors grassland over the current Arctic
tundra the soil compaction of large
mammal grazers allows for deeper
freezing in the winter this prevents the
release of greenhouse gases because
firmer terrain keeps grass from totally
fine during the summer
[Music]
wooly mammoths themselves would look a
little different if they still existed
they'd have to adapt to warmer
temperatures and beat out their rivals
the other grazers being brawny gives
animals dominance over a landscape but
it also requires much more food which is
a vulnerability so woolly mammoths would
be smarter than they used to be and
maybe lose some of that thick blanket of
fur with increasing temperatures they'd
also be a target for the ivory trade in
Siberia melting permafrost is unearthing
woolly mammoth tusks which are worth
around $1,000 per kilogram highly
sought-after ivory is exported to China
where it's used for traditional medicine
ornaments and jewelry in order for the
species to survive in the wild they
would require legal protection and
enforcement even with protection their
population would be low
a female mammoth is not sexually mature
until age 15 and her pregnancy with one
calf lasts 22 months while woolly
mammoths don't actually exist today
scientists from around the globe are
trying to bring them back this process
is called D extinction and uses
resurrection biology none have been
completely successful yet it still begs
the question of whether we should be
trying although it sounds cool to
potentially see these amazing creatures
back on our planet we can't know the
ripple effects it may have on ecosystems
and fictional warnings say don't have
the best track record for reviving those
creatures Jurassic Park anyway a better
use of our energy would be to make sure
they're endangered cousins the Asian
elephants continue to have wild habitats
to survive and are kept safe from
illegal hunting which would be easy if
we set aside half the planet for
wildlife conservation but that's a story
for another what if
[Music]